[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est Paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux on commence avec les nouvelles
d'Internet et évidemment la nouvelle
c'est le projet trinax 2023 notre projet
pour emmener les étudiants sur le
terrain en Afrique du Sud pour former
les paléontologues sud-africain de
demain vient d'exploser la barre des
200% donc merci merci à tous d'avoir
soutenu le crowdfunding sur Ulule merci
de rendre sa possible le projet trinax
reste ouvert jusqu'au 5 juillet jusqu'au
5 juillet vous pouvez continuer à nous
aider à nous soutenir en partageant ou
bien en faisant une donation comme vous
voulez partager le projet trinax c'est
déjà soutenir le projet trinax et un
grand merci à Valentine de sciences de
comptoir d'avoir rendu ça possible nous
avons défini de nouveaux objectifs avec
plus de vidéos à la clé pour Valentine
donc n'hésitez pas à continuer à
partager et à contribuer au projet
trinax et encore merci on continue avec
une curiosité curiosité vraiment bizarre
on a retrouvé une dent de mégalodon sur
l'épave du Titanic est-ce que ça veut
dire que le requin géant du milieu scène
a survécu jusqu'à nos jours et
responsable du naufrage du célèbre
paquebot et bien non évidemment non
le mégalodon est toujours une espèce
éteinte et ce qu'on a retrouvé en fait
c'est une dent fossile qui était en fait
monté en pendentif c'est ce que vous
voyez apparaître maintenant sur cette
vidéo un petit zoom sur la Dent du
mégalodon alors on reconnaît bien le
l'anatomie d'une dent de mégalodon parce
que elle est triangulaire exactement
comme une dent de requin blanc mais
contrairement à une dent de requin blanc
en fait elle a une sorte de collet vous
voyez ici en jaune c'est une sorte de
collet et donc ce Collet a été
visiblement peint en or et la dent a été
montée en pendentif et vous voyez qu'en
fait elle a été retrouvée au milieu
d'une sorte de trésor vous voyez des
perles autour par exemple vous voyez ici
des dents de babyrusa ici monté en
pendentif enfin des de babyrusa montée
en paraly et tout ce petit monde allait
certainement être vendu sur un marché
quelque part en Amérique alors vous
remarquerez quand même que cette dent de
mégalodon elle est un peu petite
comparée aux défenses de Baby Roussa on
pourrait douter qu'il s'agit du
mégalodon mais c'est vraiment le collet
qui indique qu'il s'agit d'une dent de
mégalodon il y a pas besoin que la danse
soit énorme pour être une dent de
mégalodon ils font il faut cette forme
triangulaire comme le requin blanc mais
la différence avec le requin blanc c'est
la présence du collet ici donc le collet
c'est cette espèce de zone à la base de
la dent qui est finalement entre la
racine et la dent et qui est absente
chez les requins blancs donc c'est ça
qui donne l'identité du mégalodon et pas
tellement la taille des dents les
grosses dents n'étaient situées qu'à
l'avant de la mâchoire des mégalodons
mais il y avait des petites dents un peu
plus à l'arrière et évidemment les
mégalodons il y avait aussi des bébés
donc les bébés mégalodon ça existe et
ils avaient des petites dents les bébés
mégalodon ne laissaient pas avec des
dangers tout ça a été filmé en fait par
l'opération Magellan donc le l'opération
Magellan qui est finalement une genre de
campagne de scan de la l'épave du
Titanic afin d'en faire un modèle 3D
donc c'est de la photogrammétrie quoi en
fait c'est à dire qu'ils prennent des
photos tout un tas de photos du Titanic
ils font aussi un scan en 3D ils
assemble tout ça pour créer un modèle 3D
en fait du Titanic qui sera consultable
en ligne et ça évitera que les gens
aillent se tuer en allant visiter les
pavs ça peut être utile vous voyez
et pour terminer ce passage en revue de
l'actualité paléontologique mais non
scientifique préhistorique planète
saison 2 oui je l'ai vu non je ne ferai
pas de critiques spécifiques enfin je
ferai pas de vidéo spécifique pour
critiquer enfin faire une critique de
préhistorique planète saison 2 parce que
préhistoric Planet saison 2 c'est la
saison 1 et c'est tout c'est exactement
la même chose que la saison 1 donc il y
en a beaucoup qui m'ont dit où la saison
2 de prehistoric Planet en fait c'est
pas une saison 2 c'est une saison 1
partie 2 et effectivement mais c'est
même en fait plus que ça c'est une
saison 1 partie 2 mais en réalité ce
sont toutes les scènes coupées qu'ils
ont pas gardé dans la saison 1 qu'ils
ont foutu dans la saison 2 donc en fait
cette saison 2 c'est un peu un
assemblage assez hétéroclite de des
scènes coupées de la saison 1
assemblés de façon plus ou moins
cohérente tous les épisodes de
préhistoric planète sont des biotopes
vous avez le vous avez la mer vous avez
le désert vous avez l'Arctique vous avez
la forêt et puis là à la fin de la
saison 2 ils avaient plus d'idées
c'était Amérique du Nord voilà
donc c'est vraiment un assemblage assez
hétéroclite de scène qui sont pas
forcément en rapport les unes avec les
autres qui correspond pas forcément à
des biotopes hyper cohérents donc ça se
voit en fait qu'ils ont vraiment été qui
sont vraiment allés chercher dans les
scènes coupées de la saison 1 ce qui
n'ont pas gardé de la saison 1 ça se
voit aussi dans le fait que c'est
beaucoup moins niveau des comportements
par exemple je mettais beaucoup plein
dans la saison 1 de la sur complexité
des comportements et du fait que c'était
un peu dommage d'avoir montré une telle
diversité d'animaux qui ont tous des
comportements hypersociaux hyper
complexes donc avoir finalement une
grande diversité d'animaux avec aucune
diversité comportementale puisqu'ils ont
tous les mêmes comportements tous hyper
complexes tous hyper sociaux et tous à
chaque fois systématiquement représenté
en train de faire une parade nuptiale
bon bah en fait c'est parce que dans la
saison 1 ils avaient viré tout ce qui a
fini dans la saison 2 à savoir tous les
autres comportements
c'est là qu'ils étaient les autres
comportements donc les comportements de
chasse les comportements un petit peu de
soi parentaux aussi des comportements un
peu solitaires aussi je les tous les
animaux de préhistorique planète ou
presque sont des animaux sociaux à là
enfin on nous montre des animaux
solitaires notamment il y a au moins une
fois dans préhistorique planète saison 2
où il y a un théropode qui chasse tout
seul
enfin enfin et en plus il me semble que
c'est un droméosauridé on a un raptor
qui ne chasse pas en meute dans
préhistorique planète et ça c'est
révolutionnaire mesdames et messieurs ça
fait très longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu ça
à la télévision
ça fait très très longtemps qu'on a pas
vu ça dans un documentaire un raptor qui
chasse tout seul donc
préhistorique planète saison 2 en fait
c'est la saison 1 c'est exactement les
mêmes animaux à deux animaux près il y a
six mots Succulus donc le crocodile
herbivore de Madagascar et il y a
adalaterium qui a mammifère il y a enfin
un mammifère dans préhistorique planète
saison 2 ça y est enfin on nous rappelle
que les mammifères étaient là oui les
mammifères étaient déjà là au mésovie
qui donc il y a quelques animaux en plus
mais pas beaucoup donc c'est exactement
la même chose que la saison 1 mais avec
les pieds sur terre voilà c'est un peu
ça préhistorique planète saison 2 c'est
un peu préhistorique le préhistorique
planète de la maturité j'ai envie de
dire
donc je vous recommande d'aller voir
préhistorique planète saison 2 j'ai rien
de plus à dire que ce que j'ai déjà dit
sur la saison 1 parce que c'est vraiment
une saison 1 bis c'est vraiment juste
les restes les restes non digérés de la
saison 1 donc j'ai rien de plus à dire
que ce que je viens de vous dire et en
plus la deuxième raison pour laquelle
j'ai rien à dire sur prehistoric Planet
2 c'est que tout ce que je pourrais vous
expliquer sur les choses qui se passent
dans préhistoric Planet 2 est déjà
expliqué à la fin de chaque épisode donc
à la fin de chaque épisode de
préhistoric Planet après le docu-fiction
il y a une partie en fait qui est
documentaire pure avec les
paléontologues qui sont interviewés pour
expliquer ce qui s'est passé dans
l'épisode et d'où ça vient ces
comportements qu'on vous a montré dans
l'épisode donc en fait tout ce que je
pourrais vous dire sur les comportements
zarbis qui se voient genre les
titanosaures qui pondent dans les
volcans par exemple ça ça a beaucoup
fait tilter les gens et pourquoi les
gens pourquoi les titanosaures ils
répondent dans des volcans
je sais pas pourquoi ils y répondre dans
des volcans mais n'empêche qu'on trouve
leurs œufs dans les traps du décan il y
a des au moins des coquilles je sais pas
si on a trouvé des œufs entiers mais en
tout cas il y a au moins des coquilles
d'oeufs de titanosaure dans les trappes
du décan voilà entre les couches de lave
donc oui oui ils ont le droit ils ont le
droit et ils voulaient
expliquent on a fait pondre les
titanosaures dans les traps du décan
malgré le fait que ça a l'air d'un
endroit complètement pété pour prendre
des œufs parce que c'est le cas parce
que c'est là qu'on a trouvé leurs œufs à
cet endroit là en Inde j'ai pas besoin
moi de faire une vidéo par dessus ça en
fait pour vous l'expliquer donc oui
allez voir préhistorique planète saison
2 parce que en plus on vous dit d'où ça
sort vous n'êtes pas obligé comme la
saison 1 d'aller faire vos devoirs et
d'aller faire des recherches sur
internet pour aller trouver les vidéos
en fait qui avait fait les producteurs
les genres de making-of là d'aller les
chercher vous même sur Internet quoi là
là ça vous est donné à la fin de
l'épisode on passe désormais à la
littérature scientifique et en fait on
va commencer finalement par une fausse
alerte
une fausse alerte parce que vous avez
certainement vu passer ou pas des
annonces comme quoi encore une fois on
avait fait une découverte qui changeait
toute l'histoire de l'humanité au Mona
Lady produisez de l'art pariétal et
aumônaie enterré ces grands morts on
avait déjà parlé de homona Lady qui est
enterré ces petits morts mais maintenant
on aurait au monalaidique qui enterrait
aussi ses grands morts ce qui veut dire
qu'en gros monalait dit aurait eu
finalement une une un comportement
d'Homo sapiens quasi moderne ou en tout
cas équivalent presque équivalent en
complexité à celui de Néandertal alors
que je vous le rappelle homo naedy avait
le cerveau d'à peu près 600 cm3
c'est-à-dire le cerveau d'un hom o
habilis en gros donc juste c'est
vraiment juste la catégorie au dessus de
Australopithecus quoi niveau taille de
cerveau aux Mona ledis c'est ouais c'est
Homo habilis c'est à peu près la taille
aussi de du cerveau de l'homme de Florès
quoi c'est dans ces eaux là donc on
aurait eu au Monaldi à petit cerveau
mais un comportement extrêmement
complexe je ne vais pas commenter sur
ces découvertes même si je trouve
qu'elles sont intéressantes pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'elles ne sont
pas publiées
tout cela n'est pas publié donc là je
vous montre les gravures attribués à
aumônaie donc vous voyez qu'il y a quand
même bon c'est pas de l'art pariétal
façon Lascaux mais c'est gravure là
c'est lignes donc quand c'est Homo
sapiens c'est considéré comme de l'art
pariétal il n'y a pas de raison de dire
que dans le cas de Mona ledis ce serait
pas de l'art pariétal même si c'est que
des lignes même si c'est que des lignes
que c'est très très abstrait au final
bon le problème c'est que c'est
extrêmement difficile d'attribuer de
l'art pariétal à une espèce en
particulier mais vous voyez qu'il y a
quand même je veux dire les lignes sont
là quoi donc si on arrive à les
attribuer au Mona Lady ce serait ça
serait effectivement voilà ce serait de
la pariétal complètement les gîtes
complètement légit
et au niveau de la de des rites
funéraires on va dire donc on savait
enfin on avait déjà fait l'hypothèse de
rite funéraire chez homona Lady parce
que dans la grotte d'inaldi il n'y a que
des squelettes d'homo malédi c'est à
dire que le site où on trouve homonaldi
bah vous voyez là c'est un schéma de la
grotte enfin non c'est Rising Star le
monde le nom de la grotte en général de
tout le système c'est Rising Star voilà
c'est écrit là et donc vous avez la
partie qui s'appelle d'inaldi et c'est
là qu'on trouve les homona Lady et donc
dans cette dans cette partie ils ont
trouvé je vous en avais déjà rapidement
parlé ils ont trouvé un squelette en
fait d'aumône-allédi avec un juvénile et
avec impossible caillou voilà c'est ce
que je vous montre là donc sur cette
pierre
associée à aumônaedy qui est
possiblement taillé il y aurait même
possiblement des lignes
c'est ce que vous voyez là et pourquoi
est-ce que je dis possiblement bah parce
qu'en fait ce que vous voyez là c'est
pas là c'est pas le rocher
c'est un modèle 3D du rocher parce que
en fait ce squelette enfin c'est de
squelettes en association n'ont jamais
été
exhumé ils sont ils ont été sortis dans
un plâtre donc le plâtre que vous voyez
là là vous voyez les bords du plâtre et
ça a été passé au scanner ça a été passé
au scanner à Grenoble d'ailleurs au
synchrotron de Grenoble donc en fait ce
que vous voyez là ce sont pas des images
du vrai squelette enfin ce sont les
images du vrai squelette mais au rayon X
est-ce que vous voyez là c'est pas le
vrai rocher c'est une reconstitution du
rocher au rayon X et donc les gens ont
été extrêmement enfin les gens les
spécialistes sur les réseaux sociaux on
était extrêmement sceptiques de ce point
de vue là parce qu'en fait c'est pas le
rocher qu'on voit là ce qu'on voit c'est
une reconstitution 3D du rocher et donc
il est pas complètement impossible que
ce qu'ils interprète comme étant des
lignes là ce soit des artefacts du scan
si on a un squelette d'un côté
domonaledi associé à un caillou qui
porte lui-même des mesure alors ça veut
dire que
omona Heidi était capable de faire les
gravures qu'on voit ensuite sur les
parois du même système de grotte et ce
serait d'autant plus probable que
homonaledi est la seule et unique espèce
humaine qu'on retrouve à l'intérieur de
cette grotte il y a pas d'autres restes
que homonale dit dans cette grotte voilà
ce qui se passe en ce moment avec homona
Lady le problème c'est que tout ça c'est
pas encore publié tout ça c'est des
préprint et le problème des préprint
c'est qu'elles n'ont pas encore été ça
n'a pas encore passé le crible de la
revue par les pairs et quand ça a pas
encore passé le crible de la revue par
le père ça veut dire qu'il y a pas
encore eu de véritables experts qui se
sont penchés sur ces articles donc il y
a que enfin s'il y a des experts
puisqu'il évidemment il y a une liste
d'auteurs et que tous ces auteurs sont
des experts évidemment tous ces tous ces
gens ici sont des paléo-anthropologues
sont des géologues sont des ce sont des
experts qui ont écrit l'article
évidemment enfin les articles évidemment
mais il n'y a pas d'experts indépendant
à l'étude qui se sont déjà penchés sur
la question et tant qu'on n'a pas la vie
de ces experts là et pour ce que j'en ai
vu sur Twitter les autres experts
indépendants de l'étude sont pas
d'accord mais la science ne se fait pas
sur Twitter je le rappelle mais pour ce
que j'en ai vu pour l'instant sur
Twitter les autres experts sont pas
super heureux il y a des il y aurait des
grosses lacunes il y aurait des grosses
lacunes et pour moi la première c'est
finalement de pas avoir sorti le modèle
du plâtre quoi c'est pourquoi avoir
laissé le Mona Lady dans le plâtre alors
que ça aurait pu permettre de voir de
première main en fait ces lignes qui
sont la connexion entre le squelette de
Mona Lady et l'art pariétal et en tant
que non expert du coup je me dois d'être
sceptique je me dois de faire un pas en
arrière et de me dire bon bah on va
attendre ce que ça devient après le
passage des experts indépendants on va
attendre ce que ça devient d'ici que ce
soit publié
donc on en reparlera de aumôna Lady et
du possible art pariétal et de du
possible
comportement funéraire mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que pour l'instant en fait ce
n'est pas pire reviewé donc pour
l'instant ça reste dans cet état où
mon expertise ne vaut rien en fait mon
expertise sur le sujet n'est pas
suffisante pour vous dire bon bah ça
c'est bon on peut travailler avec on
continue avec l'art pariétal avec un
exemple ou justement là ça a passé le
crible de la revue par les paires donc
cette fois avec Néandertal donc
Néandertal auquel on a pu attribuer par
le passé certaines peintures et
certaines gravures certaines formes
d'expression artistique
c'est trouver questionner dans sa on
s'est retrouvé dans une situation où
maintenant avec les découvertes de la
grotte mandrin en France
on a Homo sapiens ce qui était là dès
55000 ans en Europe en Europe de l'Ouest
donc en fait toutes les formes d'art
attribuées à Néandertal qui sont plus
jeunes que 55000 ans bah du coup on est
plus sûr de si elles ont été faites par
Néandertal ou pas c'est à dire qu'on
avait cette idée que Néandertal était
union moderne à une commission
comparable à Homo sapiens justement
parce qu'on avait des formes d'art
attribués à Néandertal en Europe de
l'Ouest sur la base de leur âge sur la
base du fait que ces formes d'art
avaient été datées de plus de 40 000 ans
et que en Europe de l'Ouest on n'avait
pas homo sapiens à plus de 40 000 ans
donc c'était la date de ces formes d'art
qui donnaient l'attribution à Néandertal
sauf que maintenant qu'on a la grotte
mandrin à 55000 ans qui a déjà de l'homo
sapiens supposé
bah on est bien embêté on est bien
embêté et donc là on nous propose une
nouvelle localité la roche Cotard qui
nous donne de nouvelles preuves que
Néandertal pratiquait une forme d'art là
en l'occurrence des gravures sur des
murs d'une grotte que je m'empresse de
montrer ici voilà donc ce voyez là la
photo de la gravure et ici
l'interprétation de la gravure donc ce
qu'on voit en fait c'est c'est pas tant
des gravures que des grosses traces de
doigts dans de la dans de la graisse
humide on va dire donc on a les traces
des doigts des Néandertal c'est assez
émouvant dans la glaise humide et tout
ça est daté là on a même une figure vous
voyez en forme d'ogive donc c'est
vraiment il y a vraiment une tentative
de représentation là il y a même une
pseudo bestiole à quatre pattes
donc on a vraiment des tentatives de
représentation on a vraiment quelque
chose qui est pas si abstrait que ça au
final
et il y en a beaucoup et tout ça ça a
été daté alors ça a pas réellement été
daté directement mais la fermeture de la
grotte a été datée d'entre 51 et 57000
ans donc elle était plus accessible on a
la fermeture de la grotte ici placée à
la marque 50 bon là il le place à 57 +
41 mais bref dans cette intervalle là on
a la fermeture de la grotte et donc on a
l'occupation de la grotte qui est datée
d'à peu près dans ces eaux là donc
quelque part entre 100 000 et en gros
60000 ans là d'après les dates qu'ils
obtiennent en gros ça n'a pas pu être
fait par qui que ce soit d'autre que
Néandertal et donc on aurait toujours
finalement ces formes d'art
pratiquées par Néandertal toujours
attribuable en fait à Néandertal même si
celle qui sont plus tardives
comme la grotte d'El Castello par
exemple qui est à 40000 ans en Espagne
même si celle-là bah du coup c'est trop
jeune pour pouvoir exclure Homo sapiens
là on est sur quelque chose qui serait
suffisamment vieux pour pouvoir exclure
jusqu'à preuve du contraire que ça a été
fait par Homo sapiens donc finalement on
aurait une on aurait eu un mois de juin
2023 ou aumône-allédi deviendrait un
artiste et où l'homme donnaitandertal
ré-obtient ses galons d'artistes aussi
donc ça ça soulève plein de questions
quand même d'avoir d'autres espèces que
simplement Homo sapiens c'est vrai
qu'encore une fois on est dans un dans
une mouvance philosophique en ce moment
où on veut attribuer aux autres espèces
du genre Homo des traits qu'on considère
comme moderne et que qui était par les
générations de chercheurs précédents
attribués uniquement Homo sapiens donc
les on reproche au chercheur précédent
d'avoir d'avoir fait de
l'anthropocentrisme d'avoir fait d'Homo
sapiens la seule et unique espèce
intelligente du genre Homo maintenant on
est dans une mouvance où on cherche à
réattribuer finalement à d'autres
espèces du genre Homo les des
caractéristiques qui est autrefois
étaient interprété comme uniquement
moderne mais il faut bien voir que cette
anthropocentrisme n'était pas sorti de
nulle part l'anthropocentrisme qui
consiste qui consiste à dire Homo
sapiens est l'auteur des de l'art
pariétal jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est pas un anthropocentrisme parce que
on croit qu'on est les meilleurs c'est
un anthropocentrisme qui est basé sur le
principe d'actualisme c'est l'actualisme
qui nous condamne à l'anthropocentrisme
c'est parce que on ne peut pas faire
autrement que comparer les les formes
d'expression artistique anciennes aux
formes d'expression artistique moderne
et qu'est-ce qu'on a comme forme
d'expression artistique moderne celle
d'Homo sapiens un point c'est tout
c'est bien ça le problème c'est qu'on a
que Homo sapiens un point c'est tout qui
produit de l'art aujourd'hui parce que
on est la seule espèce survivante donc
oui on est très prudent et a raison
quand on voit de l'art pariétal qui
pourrait être attribué à Néandertal et
oui on est très prudent quand on voit de
l'art pariétal qui pourrait être
attribué à nos monnaie
l'art pariétal attribua Néandertal il
faut faire très très gaffe que la date
ne chevauche pas une date où il y avait
déjà Homo sapiens en Europe de l'Ouest
parce que autrement on pourra jamais
être sûr si c'était Néandertal ou
sapiens ce qu'il l'a fait quand bien
même on a association avec des outils
moustériens comme c'est le cas avec la
roche Cotard donc le Moustérien ce sont
les outils de données endertale avec
aumône-allédi on a la le système rising
star avec la grotte d'inaledi et donc là
on aurait des gravures associées
uniquement avec des restes de monaïdis
qui tendraient quand même à suggérer que
c'est au monnaie analedique qui a fait
ses gravures ou alors Homo sapiens s'est
passé par là et
n'a laissé aucune trace c'est pas
impossible non plus c'est pas
complètement impossible non plus c'est
peu probable mais bon c'est pas
impossible non plus donc on va rester
faut rester prudent mais faut pas perdre
de vue en fait faut pas faire de
faut pas faire de lentilles
anthropocentrisme primaire en fait
là-dessus c'est à dire que faut pas
distribuer faut pas distribuer le le
mérite de l'art pariétal comme des
bonbons pèses à toutes les espèces du
genre Homo on est toujours coincé avec
le principe de l'actualisme on est
condamné à un anthropocentrisme
épistémique par le principe d'actualisme
qui est le fondement même de la science
enfin des sciences historiques
finalement et notamment de l'archéologie
et de la paléontologie on continue avec
ça et l'entrepuce ça et l'entropulus
notre bien-aimé Toumaï pour les intimes
plus anciens représentant de la ligne
humaine avec ses 7 millions d'années ça
et l'entropus on a dit qu'il était
bipède on a dit qu'il était quadrupède
et on a un nouvel article qui arrive
dans le Journal of human evolution qui
vient d'être publié et qui nous dit en
fait non il était quadrupède alors
résumé des épisodes précédents histoire
de comprendre à la base il y a le crâne
de Silent opus donc le crâne qu'on
appelle qu'on surnomme tout my donc ce
crâne de Sael anthropus il a été
reconstitué parce qu'il était un petit
peu il était un peu écrasé mais il a été
reconstitué et donc dans cette
reconstitution le trou occipital c'est à
dire le trou d'entrée de la moelle
épinière et reconstituer comme étant
sous le crâne ce qui indiquerait une
entrée de la moelle épinière par le
dessous à la verticale et donc qui dit
moi l'épinière verticales dit bipède
vertical soul crâne il n'y a pas
d'autres moyens d'arriver à faire ça que
de que d'être bipède donc d'après le
trou occipital du crâne on pensait que
Toumaï était bipède donc bipède on
sous-entend bipède terrestre obligatoire
c'est ça qu'on entend pas qu'on
sous-entend par bipède puisque
évidemment c'est ce qu'on retrouve chez
Homo sapiens ce moderne la bipédie
terrestre obligatoire
obligatoire sous-entendu qui laisse des
grosses traces d'adaptation sur le
squelette c'est ça qu'on entend par
obligatoire si elle est facultative
comme les comme les chimpanzés par
exemple bipédit terrestre facultatif ça
ne laisse pas d'adaptation franche sur
le squelette donc là on a une adaptation
franche à la bipédie sur le crâne donc
on pense bipédie terrestre obligatoire
ensuite est arrivé le reste du squelette
de Sael anthropus alors on sait pas si
c'est Toumaï on n'est même pas
complètement sûr que ce soit ça une
anthropus mais disons que par
élimination
il y aurait peut-être un squelette voilà
ça serait attribuable à ça et
l'entreprise donc on a eu le fémur
notamment le fémur de silenthropus qui
dont une équipe qui a eu accès au
matériel dit il était bipède et dont une
autre équipe qui n'a pas eu accès au
matériel dit qu'il était en fait
quadrupède et puis maintenant on a le
nouvel épisode le nouvel épisode c'est
qu'en regardant l'ulna c'est à dire un
des eaux de l'avant-bras de attribuer en
tout cas à ça et l'entreprise mais bon
on est toujours pas plus sûr de
l'attribution de ces eaux à ça et
l'entreprise mais en partant du principe
que c'est ça et l'entropus encore une
fois par élimination
ils en viennent à la conclusion que cet
avant-bras cette os de l'avant-bras
c'est une nappe montre une adaptation à
la quadrupédie et pas n'importe quel
type de quadrupédie une quadrupédie
terrestre obligatoire à savoir ce qu'on
appelle le knuckle walking c'est à dire
comme les chimpanzés et les gorilles
to my enfin ça et l'entreprise aurait
marché sur ces phalanges quand il se
déplaçait au sol et ça c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant parce que le knuckle
walking la marche sur les phalanges au
sol c'est un trait qu'on retrouve
évidemment chez les chimpanzés et chez
les gorilles et jusqu'à présent on
pensait que c'était une évolution
convergente on pensait en fait que
l'ancêtre en commun de chimpanzé des
gorilles et des humains étaient bipède
ou quadrupède arboricole on sait pas
trop on privilégie pour l'instant le
consensus privilégié plutôt la bipédie
arboricole mais en gros on pensait que
l'ancêtre en commun était arboricole et
de petites tailles et que c'est en
devenant plus massif plus gros que les
gorilles et les chimpanzés auraient
acquis une quadrupèdie terrestre
obligatoire tout simplement parce que
c'est une fois qu'on est trop gros c'est
difficile de se déplacer dans les arbres
donc ils auraient appris à se déplacer
au sol de façon quadrupède et donc
convergente de façon convergente aurait
évolué le enfin réa acquis le
knucklewalking la capacité à marcher sur
les points ou sur les phalanges et
surtout le nucklewalking est pas
exactement le même chez les chimpanzés
et les gorilles donc ça soutenait on va
dire l'idée que ça avait été acquis de
façon convergente sauf que bah si ça est
l'entropulse était effectivement un
kuckle walking aussi un knuckle Walker
aussi bah ça change un peu tout ça
change un peu tout puisque là on aurait
le trio de base au mini
Panini et gorilliné donc chimpanzé
gorille humain qui aurait été
knucklewalking au moins à la base de
leur évolution et du coup ça veut dire
que si on optimise à l'ancêtre en commun
bah lui aussi aurait été knucklewalking
donc c'est très intéressant si c'est
vrai alors est-ce que c'est vrai et bien
cet article nous propose nous propose
quand même des analyses assez poussées
alors ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'ils
ont pris une photo en vue latérale du de
l'ulna de Toumaï ce qui n'est pas ce qui
vous est représenté ici ça c'est un
humain moderne et puis ils ont fait ce
qu'on appelle une analyse de contour
donc bon
en un mot commençant il y a des outils
statistiques qui permettent de faire le
tour en fait d'une forme donnée en
photographie quoi et en fait ça permet
de transformer cette forme en quantité
en chiffres et ensuite on peut faire des
analyses sur cette quantité et notamment
on peut faire vous voyez des graphes et
surtout on va faire des PC c'est à dire
des analyses en composantes principales
qui permettent de représenter tout ça
dans un espèce de graphe en 2D qui est
quand même vachement plus facile à
interpréter bien que là ce soit quand
même un sacré bordel mais c'est quand
même vachement plus facile à interpréter
qu'une forme en fait donc
on transforme on a on utilise des outils
voilà graphiques et statistiques pour
transformer une forme en une quantité
qu'on va pouvoir ensuite représenter
sous la forme d'un graphique en deux
dimensions donc si on prend le jus la
sève ce que vous dit ce graphe
globalement c'est que si vous prenez
uniquement le jus uniquement la sève des
analyses qu'ils ont faites pour en tirer
le maximum d'informations TM 266 donc ça
elle entropus devait être un knuckle
Walker il devait être un quadrupède
obligatoire terrestre
voilà ce que nous disent cette analyse
et alors d'où est-ce que ça vient ça et
bien ça vient en fait de la courbure du
de l'ulna en fait donc là les bipèdes
ont un une là donc les bipèdes comme
nous ont annuler très droit alors que
les knucklewalker les ceux qui marchent
au sol sur leur point ou sur leur
phalange eux ils ont un nul n'a très
fortement courbé alors et ça ça se ça se
ça s'illustre très bien sur la figure
suivante voilà ici donc là vous avez un
chimpanzé là vous avez un hominidé dont
on parlera un petit peu après donc on
voit bien la courbure ici de Luna alors
que chez un humain moderne ici vous
voyez que c'est tout droit alors d'où
viendrait cette courbure c'est quand
même la première question est-ce que
parce que bon en pratique on voit une
courbure mais est-ce que cette courbure
a une réelle signification d'un point de
vue fonctionnel alors eux ils disent que
oui évidemment parce que il y a la
surface donc le sol le point s'appuie
comme ça sur la surface et en fait
l'énergie enfin le poids est soutenu
côté dorsal donc de ce côté là le côté
extérieur du bras là c'est l'os en fait
qui transmet immédiatement toute la
toute la contrainte jusqu'à votre coude
donc en fait il se passe pas grand chose
du côté dorsal par contre du côté
ventral ici vous avez de la chair vous
avez de la viande là et donc c'est
muscles là les muscles flexeurs ils vont
encaisser
l'impact enfin pas l'impact mais les
vrais contraintes du knuckle walking
vont être encaissées ici de ce côté-là
par les muscles et donc quand les
muscles encaisse des contraintes
qu'est-ce qu'ils font bah ils deviennent
plus fort ils deviennent et surtout ils
ont besoin d'être attachés de façon plus
plus robuste aux deux extrémités et ça
ça va ça va finalement résulter en
annonce qui va être plus courbé donc
avec plus de surface d'attache de chaque
côté des extrémités et qui va être aussi
plus épais de chaque côté résultant en
cette courbure en fait
une courbure comme ça qu'on ne voit pas
chez l'être humain en tout cas c'est ça
qu'il propose en tout cas c'est ça qui
nous explique alors après est-ce que
c'est censé ou pas ça je n'ai pas les
compétences pour vous le dire ce
pourquoi j'ai des compétences par contre
c'est mes bordel elle est où la photo de
Luna de Toumaï c'est quoi ce délire là
vous avez un article entier qui parle de
l'une note to my vous avez la figure
principale qui vous fait qui vous montre
humain chimpanzé des fossiles mais pas
tout mailles
vous pouvez faire un article entier
surtout miles sans jamais nous montrer
la photo du Toumai malheureusement je
suis généreux je vous ai fait un petit
photomontage exprès pour vos yeux ébahis
mais quand même c'est abusé je garantis
pas que tout my là est à l'échelle mais
au moins au moins ça permet de vous
montrer cette courbure dont il vous
parle là parce que il y a tout un
artiste c'est délire c'est délire il y a
tout un article sur Luna Luna de Toumaï
et comment qu'il est trop courbé comment
qu'il est trop nukle Walker
sans vous montrer la moindre image de
Luna de Toumaï je veux dire même si vous
avez même pas les droits à l'accès de la
photo droit que je m'attribue moi-même
et je m'en fous je fais un copier-coller
mais même si vous n'avez pas le droit à
la d'accès à la photo vous pouvez au
moins redessiner tu vois te redessiner
c'est autorisé tu vois
au moins le redessiner ici pour
l'illustrer quoi parce que
on a tout un article sur Toumaï sans
lunettes tout Mike quoi waouh bon bref
donc voilà l'une note to my et on arrive
effectivement bien à voir que il est
plus épais que homo et qu'il est plus
courbé que moi et au moins aussi courbé
voire même un petit peu plus que le Luna
de du chimpanzé donc au moins là c'est
visuel quoi là au moins c'est visuel
donc en partant du principe que cette
courbure est effectivement
fonctionnellement
valide et fonctionnellement lié au
kucklewalking et en partant du principe
que la 6000 il y a une similarité assez
évidente entre Toumaï tu es enfin ça et
l'entropus le Luna attribué à ça et
l'entropus TM 266 et les knucklewalkers
on peut faire l'hypothèse raisonnable du
coup que effectivement Toumaï montrait
des adaptations montré au moins 7
adaptation là
et donc ils ont ils en émettent
l'hypothèse que peut-être Toumai donc
peut-être ça et l'entreprise de manière
générale pas que tout Mike mais
peut-être que ça a une entropus était
knuckle Walker ou en tout cas montrer
certaines adaptations à la quadrupédie
terrestre sur les phalans et ça c'est
très intéressant comme je vous le disais
puisque ça suggérer qu'en fait on aurait
peut-être un ancêtre en commun avec les
chimpanzés et les gorilles qui étaient
déjà knuckle Walker ce qui est quand
même ce qui serait quand même un
changement de consensus assez violent
étant donné qu'on pensait jusqu'à
présent comme je vous l'ai dit tout à
l'heure qu'on était plutôt
bipède arboricole alors est-ce que ça
change des choses pour tout le reste
est-ce que ça veut dire what to my il
était pas bipède donc il était pas
humain non je vous renvoie encore une
fois à la vidéo que j'ai faite sur ça
elle entropus je vous la mets en
description ça ne veut pas parce que on
n'est pas bipède obligatoire enfin
bipède terrestre obligatoire ne veut pas
dire qu'on n'est pas humain ça c'est de
l'essentialisme
ça c'est c'est pas beau c'est caca c'est
sale faut pas faire ça c'est pas parce
qu'on n'est pas bipède terrestre
obligatoire qu'on ne peut pas être lié à
la lignée humaine Toumai il a toujours
des canines hyper réduites alors que son
bourrelet supra orbitaire indique que
c'était un mâle donc on a et il a en
plus une crête sagitale aussi donc ça il
a quand même des caractères mal super
développé la crête sagitale le bourlet
sus orbitaire mais il a des toutes
petites canines et ça c'est aussi un
caractère humain donc faut pas le faut
pas le perdre de vue ça et puis il a
toujours en tout cas même si c'est
débattu il a toujours en tout cas le
consensus admet toujours que le trou
occipital est situé quand même
relativement en dessous du crâne on va
pas on va pas trop tergiverser là-dessus
mais en gros il y a toujours des
caractères qui relient tout my à la
lignée humaine quand bien même on
admettrait qu'il était complètement
quadrupède terrestre voilà d'autant que
là en plus ça rendrait la quadrupédie
terrestre donc le knuckle primitif or si
vous connaissez bien ma chaîne vous
savez qu'on ne classifie pas les
êtres vivants avec des caractères
primitifs la classification sur la base
de caractères primitif c'est pour les
gens qui vivaient dans les années 40
aujourd'hui on utilise des synapophores
des caractères dérivés partagés parce
que seuls les caractères dérivés
partagés sont le signe d'un ancêtre en
commun alors que les caractères
primitifs par définition vous le
partagez avec plein d'ancêtres en commun
ou bien dit autrement si vous utilisez
des caractères primitifs pour classifier
le vivant un arbre est un invertébré
et oui et oui Jamy je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai j'ai commencé à prendre ce ton et
oui Jamie si tu classifie avec des
caractères primitifs alors un arbre est
un invertébré voilà voilà
bref
ce qu'il y a de très très intéressant
avec cet article et qui a été
complètement passé à la trappe par les
médias en tout cas sur la communication
à propos de l'article en question parce
que ça évidemment il y a eu plein de
communication au niveau des médias sur
évidemment si tout my et quadrupède
évidemment que ce n'est plus un être
humain évidemment non ça ne marche pas
mais en tout cas ce qui était très
intéressant avec cet article et bah
c'est un autre une NAT en réalité un
autre une NAT qui est je vous l'ai
évoquer tout à l'heure et puis je l'ai
je l'ai mis de côté maintenant on va en
parler c'est oh 36 ohh36 qui nous vient
d'Afrique de l'Est et qui est très très
courbé et qui à la base a été classifié
comme appartenant à part entropus
sauf que par entre opus c'est un bipède
très très franc on a suffisamment de
restes de parenthropus aujourd'hui pour
dire non mais pas entre puces il était
bipède il y a aucun doute donc là il y a
un problème il y a un problème avec
cette oh 36 cette ulna et ce qu'il faut
savoir à propos de cette huile là c'est
qu'il a été retrouvé tout seul
et que la seule raison pour laquelle on
a dit qu'il appartenait enfin la
principale raison pour laquelle on a dit
qu'il appartenait à part entropus
bah c'est parce qu'il ressemble pas à
Homo si ça ressemble à de l'hominidés
mais que ça ressemble pas au mot ses
parents trop puce voilà donc ça a été un
peu mis à la corbeille en mode on s'en
fout c'est pas homo et puis là du coup
il regarde au H36 et donc oh 36 dans
leurs analyses c'est le seul hominé à
part tout maille qui tombe dans les
knuckle Walker donc il est là vous voyez
on revient à ce tableau là celui avec
toute la sève avec tout le jus et on
voit que H36 c'est le seul avec to my
qui tombe parmi les Knuckles Walker et
du coup ce qu'il nous propose donc
évidemment ils vont pas proposer que
parenthropus était knuckle Walker
puisque comme j'ai dit c'est quand même
assez solidement établi que ce n'était
pas le cas avec des restes beaucoup
moins fragmentaires que juste annulent
isolé
donc ce qui propose c'est que eh oh ce
serait pas planté est-ce que Oh 36 ne
serait pas un chimpanzé fossile de 2
millions d'années
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas là la première
preuve d'un chimpanzé fossile je
rappelle que les chimpanzés ah non il
est pas à 2 millions d'années pardon il
a 1,2 millions d'années j'ai pas mis le
dos au bon endroit 1,2 millions d'années
est-ce qu'on aurait pas là le plus vieux
chimpanzé fossile à 1,2 millions
d'années je rappelle que le registre
fossile des chimpanzés c'est ma cache
c'est zéro c'est nada il y a quasiment
rien il y a quasiment rien de registre
fossile de chimpanzé fossiles et là
soudainement on se rend compte que merde
ce machin qu'on a mis à la corbeille en
mode c'est pas humain on s'en fout c'est
pas entre puces zut peut-être qu'en fait
ce serait un nul nat et ça enfin ce sera
un nul là de chimpanzé et ça mesdames et
messieurs ceux de la bombe de balle
parce qu'on n'avait pas de fossiles de
chimpanzé jusqu'à présent on remplirait
peut-être enfin le registre fossile des
chimpanzés
et ça c'est de la et ça c'est de la
bombe c'est génial ça ça a été
complètement passé sous silence pas la
presse alors qu'un mon avis c'est quand
même le découvertes de folie de fou ça
aurait dû finir dans nightcher on a
enfin un chimpanzé fossile à 1,2
millions d'années la folie la folie et
on va terminer avec les hominés par une
petite curiosité parue dans CNAS donc
une petite curiosité mais quand même
dans un gros journal parce que Fnac
c'est quand même pas c'est quand même
pas un journal de Guignol c'est un gros
journal avec cette étude où ils ont
utilisé des mannequins sur lesquels ils
ont mis différentes
perruques ou pas de perruque et en fait
ils ont étudié avec des capteurs à
l'intérieur à quel point la présence des
perruques influençait la régulation de
la température
et ce qu'ils ont trouvé c'est qu'en fait
les cheveux crépus les cheveux ce qu'ils
appellent les cheveux crépus serrés donc
les cheveux crépus
permettent une meilleure régulation de
la température du corps ça ça permet
notamment de réduire la transpiration
enfin vu que du coup ça garde bien la
tête au frais ça permet de réduire la
transpiration et donc ce serait un
avantage adaptatif très très
significatif
pour des êtres humains qui auraient
évolué en savane et qui donc aurait été
très très sensible à la déshydratation
donc en fait les cheveux crépus ce
serait ni plus ni moins qu'une
adaptation à un mode de vie un mode de
vie dans des dans les latitudes chaudes
en réalité ce serait une adaptation à un
fort ensoleillement exactement comme le
serait finalement la couleur de peau
donc le combo avant on pensait en fait
que le combo cheveux crépus pot foncé
c'était plus une conséquence on va dire
c'était plus un effet secondaire c'est à
dire que les cheveux seraient crépus
parce qu'il serait très riche en
mélanine ce qui rédige rédifierait les
fibres du cheveu les fibres de kératine
et du coup les rendrai plus voilà
spontanément elle se elle s'enroulerait
on va dire
elles sont durées à cause de la richesse
en mélanine à l'intérieur de la fibre
et là en fait ce que nous propose cet
article c'est qu'en fait peut-être pas
ça se trouve c'est une adaptation de
plus contre un fort ensoleillement
contre la chaleur permettant de de
garder finalement plus d'eau et de du
coup ce sera un avantage adaptatif
d'avoir les cheveux crépus donc ça
aurait pu tout à fait évoluer de façon
indépendante à la peau noire on est
élargit un petit peu notre notre horizon
maintenant on va parler des primates et
cet article paru encore une fois dans
une assez prestigieuse revue à
procédingsby c'est une revue assez
prestigieuse qui nous propose une étude
des comportements de branlette chez les
primates je vous jure c'est pas
seulement la branlette c'est aussi la
masturbation féminine et il constate que
c'est quand même plutôt nos proches
parents parmi les singes qui sont les
plus gros branleurs de la terre voyez
donc les lémuriens et leurs proches
parents les strips syriens ainsi que les
tarsiers
se branle pas tant que ça c'est ce que
vous représente c'est ces cases ainsi
c'est noir ça branlette si c'est gris ça
branlette pas trop et donc chez les chez
les lémuriens et les tartieu ça va on se
la touche pas trop par contre chez les
singes donc ce qu'on appelle les plats
Irina chez les singes et aussi et
beaucoup chez les grands singes que vous
voyez ici ça se branle mais copieusement
[Musique]
voilà voilà voilà voilà
et du coup parce que après avoir fait
cette constatation tout à fait cocasse
n'est-ce pas là on se dirige quand même
vers Nick Nobel de façon assez assez
clair ils font différentes hypothèses
ils ont fait quelques analyses
statistiques pour essayer de voir si ça
corrélé avec d'autres comportements ou
d'autres d'autres éléments biologiques
notamment
les pathogènes donc ce serait un
comportement anti pathogène de se
masturber alors surtout chez les mâles
ils insistent quand même c'est sur tous
les mâles ce sera un comportement anti
pathogène d'après eux parce que ça
expulse vivement une bonne éjaculation
expulse un peu tout le brin que vous
avez dans le conduit tout le brin de ce
tuyau comme on dit chez moi
et une fois que tu as plus de bras en
tuyau tu es quand même vachement mieux
et du coup le et du coup bon après pour
le comportement féminin ils ont un peu
de mal à expliquer du coup ils ont
essayé de voir si ça corrélé avec les
diverses comportements sociaux diverses
structures sociales notamment vous savez
que chez les singes il y a quand même
pas mal de différentes structures
sociales avec des structures qui sont
qui sont pas très linéaires des
structures qui sont matrilinéaires je
vous renvoie vers la vidéo que j'ai fait
sur le livre de Pascal pic sur
l'évolution de la sexualité je voulais
remettrai en description aussi mais bref
il y a différentes structures sociales
et sexuelles chez les singes y compris
les grands singes mais ça a pas l'air de
corréler de trop ça a l'air de plutôt
corréler avec une un comportement anti
pathogène on va dire
mais là là où j'ai amené quand même à
adresser c'est que comme il le souligne
très bien d'ailleurs dans leur article
il semble quand même y avoir une
structure phylogénétique non négligeable
c'est à dire que vous voyez là il y a
quand même un Cloud tout entier où il y
a quasiment pas de masturbateur et là
vous avez un CLA de tout entier de bons
gros et généralement quand
vous avez une structure qui est
filogénétiquement
contrainte à ce point là
ça veut dire que ça c'est l'opposé en
fait de ce que vous attendez d'une
adaptation une adaptation ça aura
tendance à se développer plein de fois à
évoluer de façon convergente parce que
c'est un avantage si ça amène un
avantage il y a plus de chances que ça
se développe plein de fois pourquoi
quelque chose qui est un avantage
évolutif n'évoluerait qu'une seule fois
chez l'ancêtre en commun de tous bons
monde alors même que
dans ce dans ce cloud là ça n'évolue
presque pas donc il reste l'hypothèse
que bah c'est juste l'ancêtre en commun
qui est développé la masturbation et
puis bah comme c'est pas contre
sélectionné que c'est pas anti-sélection
naturel de se masturber c'est resté ou
bien c'est juste l'effet secondaire
aussi d'une libido sur développée c'est
possible aussi mais encore qu'ils
excluent il me semble qu'ils exclus
cette possibilité mais en tout cas c'est
une curiosité c'est une c'est encore une
autre curiosité il y a beaucoup de
curiosité dans ce Paléo news
toujours au chapitre reproduction est
toujours dans les mêmes Royal Society
publishing mais cette fois Biology
Letters donc toujours un article qui
pèse dans le game j'ai envie de dire
cette fois on a trouvé de la
parthénogénèse chez des crocodiles de la
parthénogénèse c'est-à-dire de la
reproduction asexuée crocodile qui a
donné naissance voilà crocodile femelle
qui a donné naissance à un bébé sans
sans que le sang que un mâle ne soit
finalement nécessaire à la faire donc on
a une immaculée de conception de
crocodile voici crocodile Jésus
et donc ça a fait dire aux auteurs de
cet article et ça a fait grand bruit
dans la presse en fait les dinosaures si
en fait les crocodiles sont capables de
partie nos Genèse la plupart des lézards
sont capables de partie nos genèse et il
y a beaucoup d'oiseaux aussi de cas
documentés de parthénogenèse chez les
oiseaux donc ça veut dire qu'en gros
tout ou presque tous les reptil qui sont
capables de parter nos genèse et que
donc même les dinosaures devaient être
les dinosaures disparus du mésoïque
devaient aussi être capable de
parthénogénèses ce qui veut dire qu'on a
même pas besoin de mettre de l'ADN de
grenouilles dans les dinosaures pour que
il se reproduisent pour que la vie
trouve toujours un chemin homme
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire alors
l'observation est effectivement
intéressantes ceci étant dit je pense
que la phrase que vous cherchez c'est
celle là
il est 10hunting donc il est décevant
que le bébé né de la sorte n'est pas
survécu
oui alors on a effectivement une
reproduction par parthénogenèse mais
voici le stade maximal de B de de Raptor
Jésus de crocodiles Jésus de là à aller
chercher que du coup l'ancêtre en commun
des crocodiles et des oiseaux étaient
capables de parthénogenèse et que de
fait les dinosaures et les ptrosaures et
Théo aussi capables de parthénogenèse
sur le papier oui peut-être mais enfin
on est bien d'accord que le fondement
biologique de l'aparténogenèse chez ces
animaux-là il a pas l'air de fonctionner
du tonnerre et d'ailleurs il donne des
stats en dessous notamment des
parthénogénèses chez les oiseaux en
particulier je crois que c'est chez les
dindons sur
2000 sur quasiment 2100k de
parthénogenèse chez les dindons il y en
a que 68 qui ont qui ont réellement
donné des petits et suffisamment peu qui
ont atteint l'âge adulte au final pour
qu'il nous donne vraiment des chiffres
donc
ouais s'il y a un mécanisme de
parthénogenèse chez les archosores
ouais globalement ça marche pas du
tonnerre c'est pas ça marche pas aussi
bien que chez les grenouilles donc il
faudra toujours mettre de l'ADN de
grenouilles pour combler le code si vous
voulez que votre Jurassic Park partent
en couille exactement comme dans le film
ensuite on finit avec la reproduction
des archosor avec dans la revue
nightcher écology and evolution donc
toujours une revue prestigieuse un
nouveau petit fossile voyez ce petit
fossile qui ressemble bien un petit
fossile qui est contenu dans un œuf et
pour cause c'est un petit fossile de
corytoder donc un truc qui ressemble à
un crocodile mais qui n'en est pas
réellement un c'est même d'ailleurs à
peine c'est même pas considéré comme un
vrai arcosaure c'est un archosor aux
morphe mais bref c'est un choriste d'air
donc et ce choriste d'air il est enroulé
comme s'il était dans un œuf et donc
l'analyse du du fossile montre que
effectivement il était dans un œuf un
œuf à coquille molle
ce qui document pour la première fois
que les choristonnaires pondaient des
œufs et alors ce qui est intéressant
avec cet article c'est que il documente
donc la première
occurrence d'un neuf fossiles de
choristoder mais curieusement en conclut
que l'ancêtre en commun des amiotes ici
donc il faut une grande philogénie en
incluant tous les amyotes et en mettant
le mode de reproduction des amiotes donc
viviparité en rose oviparité dans trois
couleurs différentes en fonction de du
niveau de minéralisation de la coquille
mais en gros la viviparité c'est en rose
et la rétention de l'embryon dans le
ventre s'est en bleu donc quand il y a
pas de rétention d'embryon dans le
ventre donc c'est à dire si si vous
balancez l'embryon directement en fait
vous serez en blanc
je suis pas sûr que de ce que c'est
cette couleur
et donc il conclut que l'ancêtre des
amiotes il était bleu et rose donc il
retenait l'embryon dans son ventre et il
était vivipare donc l'ancêtre en commun
des mammifères des plésiosaures des
ichtyosores les lézards des tortues des
crocodiles des dinosaures et des oiseaux
et des ptérosores ne pondez pas d’œufs
il était pas ovipare il était vivipare
selon il retenait l'embryon dans son
ventre donc comme un mammifère place à
terre en fait et ensuite ne pondez pas
d'oeuf donc lâcher directement son petit
dans la nature comme le font certains
lézards certains serpents les mammifères
donc et comme on a pu le documenter cher
certaines rares espèces éteintes
et ça c'est une conclusion curieuse
quand vous savez que le matériau de base
ce qui a motivé cette étude c'est de
découvrir un nouvel œuf de corytoder
donc de découvrir que les choristes
auder pondaient bel et bien des œufs
c'est quand même assez louche comme
résultat et personnellement je vous
avoue que je suis mi-figue mi-raisin
avec ce genre de conclusion notamment
parce que ici le plus basal de tous les
de tous les reptiles qu'ils ont inclus
c'est mésosaurus et mésosaurus il
considère que il était vivipare alors
qu'on a des enfin on a un neuf de
mésosaurus qui est d'ailleurs très très
similaire à cette oeuf ici de corytoder
donc on sait que mes osaurus n'était pas
vivipare puisqu'il promet des œufs et
ici vous avez les mosasaure et les
mosasor c'est pareil l'année dernière
enfin non c'était il y a quelques années
de ça c'était pas en covid on avait eu
le paléontologue français Lucas Legendre
qui avait décrit le premier œuf de
Mozart donc on sait que les mosasaure
était pas forcément tous vivipare même
si on a pu trouver des preuves de vie
parité chez les mosasaurs chez les
lézards de manière générale et les
serpents on sait que la viviparité enfin
ils aussi entre viviparité au veau
vigiparité oviparité enfin ça va
vraiment tous les sens chez les serpents
ça change très très vite donc chez les
serpents c'est très très variable mais
bon la plupart sont ovovivipare ou
ovipare
et donc là en ayant cette nouvelle
occurrence de corytoder on sait pas trop
comment mais ils arrivent à la fin avec
les amiotes vivipare et ça bon ça je
trouve ça curieux parce que c'est pas
par simonieux comme résultat alors ceci
dit c'est pas une reconstitution au
maximum de parcimonie c'est une
reconstitution en maximum de
vraisemblance parce que je pense qu'à
mon avis avec un algorithme de
parcimonie ils auraient trouvé les
amiottes ovipare
et mais par contre ça m'interpelle parce
que bah du coup si l'ancêtre en commun
des amiotes est
vivipare ça veut dire que les thérapies
les ancêtres des mammifères étaient
aussi vivipares et ça ça expliquerait
pourquoi on trouve pas d'oeufs de
thérapied parce que depuis 200 ans
d'histoire de découverte de thérapie
dans le carreau et ailleurs dans le
monde on a toujours pas d'oeuf de
thérapie le plus proche qu'on est passé
de la découverte d'un œuf de thérapie
c'est quand on a découvert un sinodonde
kyana
qui avait en gros vous avez un adulte
préservé avec je crois qu'il y a 38
petits
et du coup on n'a pas d'oeuf mais par
contre 38 petits ça se fait pas chez les
vivipares généralement 38 petits c'est
vraiment c'est une couvée de lézard ça
de balancer 38 petits comme ça c'est pas
un truc qui se fait chez les vivipares
donc on pense que les synodontes pondent
des œufs à cause de ça pondez encore des
œufs à cause de ça et puis évidemment
comme on a les ornithorynques et les et
les autres monotrèmes qui pondent aussi
des œufs ça soutient que la ponte des
œufs serait un caractère ancestral chez
les mammifères et que donc l'ancêtre des
mammifères pondait des œufs et que donc
l'ancêtre des amiottes ne devait pondre
des œufs aussi quoi donc je suis un peu
partagé sur ce résultat et je suis pas
encore tout à fait convaincu que
l'ancêtre des amiotes était vivipare
mais s'il l'était ça expliquerait quand
même pas mal de choses donc on reste
ouvert à cette possibilité
en tout cas selon moi ça ça c'est pas
complètement
c'est pas complètement n'importe quoi
même si c'est assez contre-intuitif et
on termine avec brouad Kaio sorus le
fameux dinosaure géant ou du moins un
des un des grands participants au
concours de Kiki c'est qui a le plus
gros Dino Bruat kaiosaurus dont une
nouvelle
estimation de poids a été tenté par
Grégory Paul et Assia la ramondi donc
Grégory Paul que vous connaissez puisque
c'est lui qui avait proposé les trois il
avait proposé que les trois morphotypes
de T-Rex étaient trois espèces
différentes
tyrannosaure Régina et tyrannosaure
imperator venant se rajouter à
Tyrannosaurus Rex et vous le connaissez
aussi parce que c'est lui qui a créé
enfin qui a fait de du brachiosaure de
Tanzanie le girafat Titan et il trouve
un poids qui se situe quelque part entre
110 et 170 tonnes ce qui
pulvérise toutes les estimations de
poids qui ont pu être fait juste avant
c'est plus ou moins 170 tonnes on
approche définitivement le poids maximum
d'une baleine bleue donc d'un animal qui
vit dans l'eau les baleines bleues c'est
200 tonnes à peu près le poids maximum
donc on approche définitivement le enfin
n'explose définitivement la barrière des
centaines et la barrière des centaines
globalement c'est considéré comme plus
ou moins la barrière
infranchissable quand vous êtes un
animal terrestre ça veut pas dire que
c'était impossible absolument impossible
mais disons qu'on commence vraiment à
des contraintes sur des ossements
qui dépassent du point de vue physique
ce scanos est capable d'endurer donc
notamment au niveau des membres quoi et
on commence à placer des contraintes au
niveau énergétique aussi que la
nourriture qui est accessible à un
moment donné à un animal donné ne va pas
pouvoir finalement entretenir alors je
sais que plus on est gros normalement
est mieux on digère quand on est
herbivore notamment plus on est gros
plus on a une grosse chambre de
fermentation donc mieux on digère plus
on est capable d'extraire de la
nourriture mais un régime herbivore
c'est quand même un régime qui est très
peu énergétique donc arrivé à dépasser à
arriver à entretenir plus de centaines
de chair avec un régime herbivore c'est
quand même compliqué donc 100 tonnes
c'est généralement considéré comme étant
la barrière la barrière interdite quoi
la barrière infranchissable donc là
approchez le poids d'une baleine bleue
alors que on est herbivore et qu'on est
terrestres sachant que la baleine bleue
c'est un animal qui est aquatique et qui
est carnivore le krill ça reste de la
protéine animale donc c'est très très
énergétique
on est quand même sur quelque chose qui
est embêtant on sait bien que les
dinosaures se reposent se foutaient un
peu de ce qui est raisonnablement
possible mais là ça fait beaucoup alors
petit aparté pour essayer de vous
expliquer rapidement et simplement en
tout cas j'espère comment ça se fait
qu'on a des estimations de poids aussi
démentielles et quel est le problème
avec ces estimations de poids et ben
c'est parce que déjà il faut se rappeler
que bruyate cayosaurus on a que des
restes très partiels on a que un tibia
et un fémur et encore le fémur est pas
complet c'est ce que cette partie en
gris vous représente alors le problème
quand on travaille avec des restes aussi
partielles et en plus je suis même pas
sûr je crois que le matos a été perdu le
problème quand on travaille avec des
trucs aussi partiels c'est qu'on peut
travailler que à partir des mesures de
ces eaux là et faire des extrapolations
et les extrapolations ça pose des
problèmes alors par exemple pour le
tibia qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait et bien
ils ont utilisé des estimations de poids
de Argentinosaurus pentagot Titan Drake
lotus et
donc des estimations de poids qui ont
été faites en faisant des modèles en
trois dimensions dont le volume a été
calculé donc eux là c'est 4 là en fait
on connaît leur volume enfin du moins on
a estimé leur volume et à partir de
cette estimation de volume et en
multipliant par la densité qu'on pense
que c'est parti du corps avaient on
obtient une estimation de poids et donc
ils ont utilisé ces estimations de poids
et celle là uniquement alors je sais pas
si vous vous rendez bien compte de
combien d'estimations de poids ont été
faites d'Argentine auxaurus ne serait-ce
que d’argentinosaurus mais en gros c'est
il y en a eu beaucoup et elles sont tous
très très différentes eux ils en ont
choisi une
celle qui est basée sur le volume et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait bah on n'a pas
de volume pour Bruat kyosaurus alors on
prend la taille du tibia la longueur du
tibia et on fait un Bed produit en croix
avec celle des autres bon en réalité on
fait une régression linéaire mais là
c'est le même principe en réalité une
régression linéaire c'est juste un
produit en croix avec plusieurs cours
reproduit en fait plusieurs fois donc
ils ont juste fait un bête produit en
croix une extrapolation voilà si le
tibia de Bruat kaiosaurus est tant de
fois plus grand que celui
d'argentinosaurus alors son poids
devrait être d'à peu près et c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive à 150 à 240 tonnes 240
tonnes je vous disais déjà que 100
tonnes c'était exagéré 240 tonnes là en
bas même les estimations les plus
ridicules qui avaient été faites de
Brachiosaurus si vous vous rappelez
Brachiosaurus dans le Guinness Book des
records il avait atteint les 180 tonnes
c'était au pifomètre total et donc là
même l'estimation pifomètre total on lui
explose sa face
et le truc en fait c'est aussi qu'avec
les donc déjà c'est pas hyper précis
c'est pas une façon hyper précise de
faire une estimation de poids mais en
plus le problème c'est que vous faites
en fait le moindre changement dans la
longueur du tibia
et ça va vous donner une énorme un
énorme changement dans le volume de
l'animal parce que rappelez-vous une
longueur c'est une mesure linéaire c'est
en deux dimensions mais un volume c'est
une c'est une mesure en 3D donc en fait
il faut multiplier au cube de la
longueur donc la moindre petite erreur
de mesure a des répercussions au cube et
ça ça se voit très très bien quand on
regarde le fémur donc le fémur dont ils
ont dû d'abord estimer la longueur c'est
à dire que c'est même pas la vraie
longueur du fémur ils ont dû estimer la
longueur avec tout ce que ça implique de
marge d'erreur et à partir de cette
longueur estimée du fémur ils estiment
pareil un poids du corps
donc pareil extrapolation régression
linéaire produit en croix ce que voilà
avec encore une fois toute la
toutes les imprécisions que ça implique
et là ça se voit très bien au niveau du
fémur parce que si vous prenez par
exemple patagot Titan le fémur de
patagot titan les mesures sont en
millimètre donc le fémur de pâte à Gau
Titan et juste 70 cm plus petit que
celui estimé de Bruat cayosaurus sauf
que du coup vous passez d'un poids de 56
tonnes pour patagon Titan à plus de 100
tonnes pour Bruat kaiosaurus vous voyez
ce que je veux dire par la moindre
petite erreur de mesure se répercute au
cube
c'est c'est juste gigantesque
donc c'est ça le gros problème en fait
c'est que extrapoler des mesures
linéaires vers un volume ça demande une
précision tellement extrême bah que du
coup on varie très facilement de
plusieurs ordres de grandeur avec des
toutes petites erreurs de mesure de
quelques centimètres à la base imaginez
faire une erreur de mesure de quelques
centimètres sur un tibia qui fait trop
enfin sur un fémur qui fait 3 mètres
c'est facile c'est très très facile donc
c'est ça le gros problème avec cet
article c'est que comme ils utilisent
des restes qui sont très parcellaires
ils peuvent pas faire une estimation du
volume de l'animal et du coup il y a des
énormes imprécisions et du coup et ça se
voit effectivement extrêmement bien
quand on regarde là ces animaux qui ont
pensé faisait des centaines de tonnes
une fois qu'on a fait des estimations de
leur volume à partir de modèles 3D bah
on est tombé sur des poids beaucoup plus
raisonnables et là comme on l'a pas fait
avec Bruat kaiosaurus on retombe encore
une fois sur plusieurs centaines de
tonnes et je vous invite à aller voir
notre vidéo sur comment on estime le
poids des dinosaures si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur comment est-ce qu'on
estime le poids d'animaux éteint
voilà c'était Paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'ancien et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]